NEAL MUELLER: Hi, I'm Neal
Mueller on the Geographic
Expansion Team.
We build the technical
infrastructure
that powers Google and
Google Cloud Platform.
This includes new
regions, points
of presence, solar
and wind farms,
and terrestrial and
submarine cable networks.
I'm here today to tell you about
a new amazing region in Sydney.
It's now open.
This isn't our first
region in Asia.
We also have Singapore,
Taiwan and Tokyo.
Our global network
connects all of our regions
together, along with our
100 points of presence
all over the world.
The Google network is
the largest network
of any public cloud provider.
Now that I've told
you about our network,
let's talk about the
Sydney region itself.
For the first time
ever, GCP users
can process and store
data locally in Australia.
As you can see from
this list of services,
the services include
compute, big data, storage
and networking.
You can find a whole lot more
about the services in Sydney
at cloud.google.com
/about/locations.
In short, the Sydney region
has everything that you need
to build and scale what's next.
And now, let's hear from
our local team in Australia
to learn what this
new region in Sydney
means for local customers.
ANGELO JOSEPH: Hi,
I'm Angelo Joseph.
I'm the head of
customer engineering
in Australia and New Zealand.
My team and I help customers
in the adoption of Google Cloud
Platform solutions to
meet their business needs
and helping them
innovate into the future.
We have thousands of customers
on our cloud platform.
The likes of Woolworths,
Halfbrick, ingogo, News Corp,
Fairfax, Service New South
Wales, and PwC to name a few.
Customers such as
Rentokil Initial
are using our data flow and
publish and subscribe services
for IoT solutions for
facilities monitoring
for up to 10,000 customers.
Others, such as
Monash University,
are using our Google App Engine
as an application service
platform.
And digital natives,
like PaperCut,
are using big query for
analytics and reporting.
What really excites me
about the Sydney region
is that it will allow
customers to store and process
data in Australia.
Our performance testing
of the Sydney region
shows 40% to 90% reductions
in the round trip time latency
when serving
customers in Sydney as
compared to other regional
options in Taiwan, Japan,
Singapore, and India.
I think customers
are going to love
having an even faster and
more local Google Cloud.
GCP has been helping
customers in Australia
and New Zealand for
more than five years,
and with our sales teams based
in Sydney, Melbourne, Brisbane,
Auckland, we have always had
a local point of presence
to connect our local customers
to Google Cloud solutions.
And now even more so that
we have a local GCP region.
So we're really excited
to see what customers
will be building there.
And finally, the
Google Cloud Summit
is coming to Australia
in September,
so I look forward to
seeing you all there.
NEAL MUELLER: That's right.
Thanks.
There's never been a
better time to get up
and running with
Google Cloud Platform.
We think GCP is the
smart, secure cloud
to help move your
business forward.
And with our new region in
Sydney, we're right next door.
We're excited to see
what you're going
to build in the Sydney region.
And remember to check out
the Google Cloud homepage
for upcoming summits near you.
Thanks.